alright Sean I think today we're gonna
skip the intro and you're just going to
go ahead and drop the beat J play that
funky music or is it the melody yeah go
ahead and do that this is where you'll
paste that in ready go
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it
welcome to the middlemost podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less so I'm Joshua
fields Milburn and I am Ryan Nicodemus
and that makes us the minimalists a
minimalist weed welcome to episode
number 15 we're calling today's episode
consumerism we have some questions about
consumption and consumerism but before
that let's let's do a little bit of
housekeeping Ryan we have a tour coming
up we do we will be on the road everyone
we're going to be on the road all
throughout May in more than a dozen
cities but even if we're not coming to
your city our documentary is so if you
want to find the theater closest to you
because you want to see the documentary
go to minimalism film comm and click on
see the film and you can find this
little map there and you can find the
theater and Saginaw Michigan or or
Lansing Michigan or East Lansing
Michigan we have a lot of showings in
Michigan I'm hoping as I'm saying this
if you're in Marilyn or Hawaii or New
Hampshire I mean we have screens and I
think maybe all 50 states now if not
really really close to that so find a
theater close to you now here's the
catch this is one night only in most
cities so it's not going to be showing
for a long time so you have to get your
tickets in advance if you don't get your
tickets in advance the screening won't
happen so we really need your help there
yeah if you're like me you wait to the
last minute and it will be too late if
you wait till the last minute right
because it won't be there until we until
we have enough enough people who have
reserved their tickets thankfully we
already have thousands of people who
have done that but many cities still
need a lot of help so do us a favor help
us out if you want to see this film you
can check out the trailer at minimalism
film calm and if you love the trailer
you love what we're doing you can get
some pretty cheap tickets you can also
come see me and Ryan on the road if you
go to the minimalists calm slash tour
you can see all of the
you know it's less than two months and
Ryan and we will be on on the road I
can't wait I'll be a lot of fun yes
someone on on periscope said didn't ver
yes the film will be in Denver we have
several screenings in Denver we won't be
there personally but we'll be on the big
screen which is also so we'll be in a
bunch of places Ryan let's go ahead and
get started we have a bunch of
voicemails our first voicemail question
is from Anna in Missouri I'm just trying
to be more careful I'm trying to be more
careful with what I buy and try to buy
better quality clothing that will last
longer and but I don't want to support
stores that do send their stuff overseas
and take advantage of other people that
work in sweatshops what do you recommend
out you are you guys know stores where
you can shop that are not involved in
sweatshops congratulations on being more
intentional with what you're trying to
do here because I think it's really
important for us to focus on not not
only bringing less into our lives but
being focused on the things that we do
bring into our lives that they're
intentional their deliberate and their
most important responsible right not not
only is it important for it to be
appropriate for our lives but we need to
be responsible for for the things that
we we consume so minimalism isn't about
not consuming it's about consuming with
intention so I'm going to recommend a
few things that I do personally and a
reader a few weeks back or listener on
this podcast a few weeks back
recommended that we visit a website so
I'm going to start with that buy it once
calm which is actually by - it - once
calm I'm looking at the website right
now and talk about they really just talk
about buying high quality products
buying durable products they're going to
last a long time so the idea is if you
need something for the rest of your life
if you can buy a once as opposed to
buying a dozen
or or hundreds of times throughout the
course of your life you're going to be
consuming more responsibly they also
have ethical purchasing on their
websites they talk about the ethics
behind the goods that they recommend and
so buy it once comm is is a great place
to start
I also advocate buying things used I
often will shop it if it's not a thrift
shop it's an online thrift shop like
eBay or Craigslist and here's the thing
about buying something used yes if you
have a good that was made in a
irresponsible way well and then you're
getting ready to throw it away if you at
least re-appropriate that thing so that
something else doesn't need to be
created then then I think you're you're
in a good position to to consume
something or to reuse something that
otherwise would just end up in a
landfill so and I'm going to recommend
you try it try to buy things used buy
things that are high quality and check
out check out whether it's eBay or next
time you need to buy a shirt which by
the way you can get a high end designer
clothes on on eBay for really
inexpensive price you know they're
gently used but Ryan isn't that what all
the kids are doing today anyway they
have fine gentiles they have to tab the
tear in their jeans yeah it's like
that's how it comes new nowadays like
you got holes and tears and phrase and
yeah collars missing and things like
that yeah it's a it's you know I think
it's impossible to to leave a you know a
zero imprint and I know man just saying
that I know I'm good we're going to have
a lot of zero waste folks some it gets
counter this but it's certainly
impractical yes yeah well I guess what
I'm saying is even with a zero waste
type culture if I go to a store and get
a cup of coffee and I bring a mason jar
there's still a lot of waste that goes
with that cup of coffee that I got that
was poured into my mason jar um so I
guess what I'm really trying to say here
is that I will try to have as little of
an impact as possible I will buy goods
that last a long time because like a
computer for example it's something that
you and I use in our everyday lives
right we run a blog
all of our businesses on the internet
that's how we have met most of our
friends now on the internet so you know
yeah so it's a great tool that we use
but there are chemicals in this laptop
there are metals in here that that will
pollute the earth once it is
extinguished once I have thrown it away
and I done Leicester I don't know of
anywhere where you can send it off to
recycle if there is let us know send us
a comment if you know where you could
send your computers off to be recycled
but my point is is when I go to buy a
tool like that I actually Apple does
that they have a recycle program yeah
right so so even better it's like I will
go out of my way to buy something that
will last a long time and then yeah if I
can recycle it afterwards I will recycle
it yeah finding any I think that's the
other end of the equation right we're
talking about bringing things into your
to your life responsibly but then
letting go of them responsibly it's one
thing to hold on to it in perpetuity
because we feel like okay I'm holding on
to this to this thing because I'm afraid
that I'm going to fill a landfill with
it well then your house just eventually
becomes a pseudo lambreaux thank you and
so finding ethical ways to let go
realising sometimes some things are
going to end up in a landfill that's
okay as long as what you're bringing to
that landfill is radically reduced
compared to what the average is and so
what we're advocating here is
responsible way of letting go I noticed
a comment on here
someone said Patagonia and I think that
that's a great point Patagonia makes
really high-end clothes and they
encourage you to buy their clothes use
and because they know that their stuff
is high-quality and it lasts lasts for a
very long time so you're not replacing
that t-shirt every year because you want
you buy something from them actually
just talking to two Becks my partner
this weekend she used to live in
Ketchikan Alaska which is the rainiest
place in North America I mean it's
unbelievable people there just leave
their windshield wipers on in the
there's like 12 days a year something
like that where it doesn't rain people
still have their windshield wipers on
because they're just dishes to it yeah
and and so she bought a Patagonia
raincoat um I think it was so it was 10
years ago 11 years ago we were just in
Seattle this this past weekend and she
was wearing it there as well as she it's
the same Patagonia and it looks freakin
brand new and and I'm so so buying
something like that and she used to wear
it every single day and catch a kid and
because all it did was rain yeah and and
so it was her sort of built-in
windshield wiper it was always on and
and so she realized that I'm never going
to but if something happens this coat
and I it gets ripped or damaged somehow
and she's had it for a dozen years or
whatever she's just going to go and buy
a very similar coat made by Patagonia
because she knows she's going to get
another 10 20 years out of that same
coat which is pretty amazing
our next voicemail question is from
Austin in San Francisco in your guys's
book living a meaningful or with a
meaningful life you recommend a specific
juicer the the omega j8003 gets a 8006
which is the number one bestseller for
juicers and looks all fancy but it costs
$70 more and I'm usually pretty good
about being conscious of what I buy but
where do I draw the line between
spending more money on better things to
improve my life and and getting sucked
into consumerism like this Austin well I
got the juice just pulled up here man
and I'm comparing them man you would be
a total chump if you didn't go with the
8006 everyone is gonna let the 8,000th
looks like the cool kids are getting the
more expensive one um no man there's no
difference I mean you're talking about
the juicer specifically there's no
difference between these two juicers
except one is stainless steel and the
other is not so if the aesthetic of if
white doesn't bother you as far as this
aesthetic goes then get the cheaper one
the stainless steel one 70 bucks more
and there's probably someone out there
who like has this beautiful stainless
steel kitchen and everything stainless
steel and they would totally spend $70
more just to get two stainless steel
juice
you know what that's okay right but if
you're talking about functionality like
me I'm gonna go for the functionality of
it yeah the the cheaper one does the
same exact thing but it's not stainless
steel I mean obviously this doesn't hold
true with every single case when you go
to buy an item like I totally went out I
had a magic bullet it was like I forget
what rpms or what wattage it was was
like a real high wattage and I'm talking
before this and he swore that it was 800
horsepower I drove it did we also put
some air over some airplane wings on it
no so it was like you know 800 800 watts
or whatever the heck it was and it was
$50 more than the magic bullet that was
200 watts less so when I went to go buy
this I was like you know what I didn't
look at any of the reviews my fault
shame on me
I don't look at any of the reviews I
just thought okay I know that the magic
bullet works well I've seen him in the
past I went for the one that was 200
horsepower the one those 200 watts less
and it's and it's kind of stinks I'm not
going to lie like the when I had the one
that was 200 horsepower more that was
before it broke it definitely worked a
lot better so it still works it still
does its job it does take longer I
really wish I would have done the
research and just went ahead and spent
the 40 or 50 bucks more that it cost so
in any of these situations it's about
doing the research going back to
consuming responsibly it was my fault
for not doing the research in that
scenario shame on me I will learn from
that lesson and do some nice comparisons
um you know when I need to buy something
in the future but with this with
specifically awesome with the juicer
dude if you don't care about whether
it's stainless steel or not like get the
one that's cheaper does the same exact
thing as a stainless steel one yeah and
Ryan's actually talking about to
high-end juicers here these are
masticating juicers which they're not
your run-of-the-mill
$50 crappy juicer that's going to break
on you these are both great juicers but
Ryan's right the main difference here
the only difference that I can tell is
the color and you're going to pay you're
going to pay 70 bucks more for that
stainless steel but in some cases Ryan's
right you need to do a comparison and
you need to look at say okay
this model of X versus Y model the the y
model $70 more what additional features
does that have okay it has these seven
additional features sounds great but are
those features going to add value to
your life the the immediate example that
comes to my mind right now Ryan is
coffee makers mmm no sigh standing
Airbnb this this weekend over in Seattle
and they had this you know high-end
coffee maker that must have had it
looked like something from the Star Trek
Enterprise main console it had all these
buttons on it computer one cup of coffee
please
real gray black and and so there are all
these options and Becca looked at me and
said there's a button there said like
strong or extra strong and I'm like that
should the coffee maker itself shouldn't
determine whether or not the quality is
strong the amount of coffee vert to
water ratio should determine and to me
like all those extra features in that
coffee maker is probably several hundred
dollars more than a v60 pour over that I
use that I usually travel with but
forgot to this weekend and and you know
what all those extra features actually
get in the way of creating something
that I want to create and so sometimes
you have to think about the additional
your bells and whistles I was just
thinking that the bells and whistles I
stick it about when we were working at
Telecom and that guy came in and he was
like alright I just want I just want you
to sell me a basic cell phone I don't
want no I don't want no phones with
bells or whistles on it and then
employee we had Mike he was like oh
you're in luck sir we just sold our last
phone with a whistle lock yeah and so so
so keep in mind that sometimes those
extra seven features or extra one
feature is worth the additional cost to
you and whether that's a a you know
higher wattage or it is a whistle a
whistle coffeemaker with a whistle yes
you met you may want that sometimes uh
well speaking of whistles I mean
literally I hate those damn teapots that
have a whistle on them because they
always whistle as the most inopportune
teapot without a whistle default pay
more for Less whistle and and so yes I I
would encourage you to keep that in mind
sometimes those extra extra features
will either get in the way or they're
not worth the extra money you're like
yeah I would pay two or three more
dollars for that extra feature
I'll wait it's $100 more of course
that's not worth it to me so keep that
in mind when you're making your next
purchase but can all congratulations
Austin you're making that that conscious
decision is okay which one is
appropriate for me and that's the
question you're asking and by
identifying what is appropriate to you
you can figure out which model works
best for you and by the way you're
looking at some high-end juicers right
now and these are juicers that are going
to last you 10 20 years as long as you
take care of them and clean them Austin
I notice here in San Francisco we have
two tour stops there it's a double
feature unfortunately both of those are
sold out but we're going to send you a
couple tickets we have some other
screenings in the Bay Area we'd love to
thanks for your question thank you for
your question by sending you a couple
tickets to a local screening of
minimalism a documentary about the
important things our next question is
from Joe and Cincinnati we hear a
question that continues to bother me
deals with one's identity being a self
proclaimed the geek flirting with the
philosophy of minimalism I find myself
with enough internal conflict keeping
your geek street cred involves playing
video games written comics watching TV
shows and movies many of us spend time
to learn the entire history or
completely fictional civilizations so
with all the blood sweat and tears yes
there's a lot of Tears because a part of
one's identity so you can see how this
inherit consumerism becomes part of the
culture we have entire conventions based
on our heroes where you're excited to
shell out the money for an overpriced
ticket so you go inside and get this I
stuff or even wait in line for three and
a half hours to pay for a photo op with
your favorite zombie killer or dwarf so
with the understanding and realization
that what you do or do not own does not
define who you are
how does one minimally express fandom
you know at as you start about being a a
geek I was showing my my sticker to the
camera here little monkey sticker that
Ella gave to me this morning she was on
the potty and she gets a sticker for
going to the potty and and you get a
sticker to you for going on the body
yeah she likes to give me stickers for
using the bathroom and and so yes I have
my monkey sticker body sticker yes yes
so you all can know that I didn't pee my
pants today Joe you talked about a bunch
of stuff here and it's a very well
worded question and and what what I love
about it seems like you scripted this
thing out and and I'm grateful for that
because the quality of our questions
will lead to hopefully better quality
answers as we're going through this Ryan
he he was talking first about identity
ease that word identity yeah and I can
tell you that what you're talking about
in terms of identity identity is
identifying with something that you care
about some your passion about something
you're interested in something that
excites you where as opposed to how most
of us think of our identity which is
that that title that's written on our
business card what our job title is one
of the first questions we ask each other
is what do you do and then we spend the
next five 10 15 minutes
laboring on about that vocation that
earns us a paycheck there's nothing
wrong with earning a paycheck but I'd
rather have my identity wrapped up in
something that's meaningful to me
whether that's you know going to these
conventions or or living a lifestyle
that is in accordance with my interests
rather than just constantly pursuing a
paycheck to to make ends meet I don't
see anything wrong with making money but
I definitely want I definitely want my
identity to be wrapped up in something
that I care about sure yeah I mean you
know it sounds like Joe identifies a lot
with being a geek he's a that's what he
said right self-proclaimed geek John's
Oh anything yeah so yeah I mean I would
say yet like you said Josh there was a
lot of things covered there I would
speak to first the
convention he talked about man you know
it's cost so much for us to go to these
conventions these Comic Cons or whatever
type of conferences they are you know if
you're spending four or five hundred
bucks on an experience and it's
something you really love to do then I I
don't think that there's anything wrong
with that I certainly wouldn't spend 500
bucks or that much money on a comic-con
ticket but I know plenty of people who
would so I you know first and foremost I
would say yeah keep keep gaining
experiences in your life I mean that's
that's why we're here on this on this
earth I mean that's the only thing we
can do is is is have as many experiences
as possible and I think that's the best
way that one can grow when it comes to
all the memorabilia man you know Josh
and I might differ a little a little bit
on this I always say if there's someone
who just absolutely loves collecting
Faberge eggs or absolutely loves to
collect comic books and comic book
memorabilia and it's truly what makes
you happy and what brings you joy then
do it you're a minimalist I give you
permission to do that and be a
minimalist but Joe I'll be honest with
you man you know you said in the you
know towards the end of your question
that a lot of this or that this has
brought on a lot of Tears so there's
obviously something here that isn't that
isn't aligning with your your values and
beliefs and you know if I was you where
would I start I would start with I don't
know I mean is it the stuff that is
making you feel overwhelmed is it the
money that is making you feel
overwhelmed is it the time that you're
spending on this stuff is that making
you feel overwhelmed but if you're
looking for somewhere to start if you're
looking for a way to still have this
hobby to still live this lifestyle and
practice minimalism I would start with
you that question that Josh always talks
about that we always talk about is how
might your life be better with less
stuff yeah but it's especially with the
tears unless there are tears of joy
because you're getting so much joy out
of the experiences right and generally
that that's what's happening and and
just echo Ryan said I wouldn't confuse
the the memorabilia the stuff the
trinkets with the experience and right
now it's
to me like you're blurring the lines
between experience and the trinkets some
of those trinkets may actually augment
your experience and that's awesome
sometimes some of the stuff that we
bring into our lives helps us enjoy that
aspect of our life even more sometimes
those things just get in the way or
they're neutral and if they're neutral
that they're effectively getting in the
way and and so I find that when I sort
of bring in the accoutrements of
memorabilia or the experience the best
time to do that is if it actually
improves the experience and if it
doesn't then I'm more I want to be more
focused on the experience I want to put
more time attention resources someone on
our periscope right now just said that
money is the transfer of energy and if I
were to a pin that at all money is is it
shows how we want to focus right and on
what we want to focus so it's a resource
that we use but it's one of many
resources that we use monies want one
resource but you're also spending your
time and your attention on on these
things and so yes a photo-op waiting in
line for three hours for a photo-op with
your favorite character or whatever
that's an action that that's an
experience and because you get to
interact with people who around you you
get to finally go up and have the photo
which by the way the photo can be stored
digitally it doesn't need to be another
thing that's taking up space and
attention in your life but you can still
have access to it I mean we all post
that stuff on social media now anyway so
it'll it'll be out there in the ether
sort of in perpetuity and I'm also -
Ryan's point about about the collecting
of stuff it reminds me of a Derek
Siver's essay which we'll put a link to
this in the show notes over at the
minimalists comm slash podcast and the
title of the essay I'm not going to read
the whole thing but I will summarize it
it's happy smart and useful and he has
this Venn diagram with with three
circles with those three things and and
and basically three things to consider
when making large life-size decisions
what number one doesn't make you happy
right now now if I were to comment on
that now I would say happiness shouldn't
be the point living a meaningful life a
Purpose Driven Life is the point and
happiness tends to be a byproduct of
that so when thinking about happiness
don't chase the happiness chase the
meaning and get happiness out of that
the second part of the Venn diagram is
what's smart meaning what's good for you
in the long term and the third thing is
what's useful to others hmm and if you
you find the intersection of those three
that's when you'll find something that
that you're going to create a peak
experience out of because if you're
collecting just for yourself because it
makes you happy in the moment but maybe
it's not good for you long-term or maybe
it's not useful for others at all then
eventually you're going to feel a source
of discontent similarly if you
experience something that is good for
you long term but maybe doesn't ever
make you happy you never feel sort of
fulfilled by it well then and it's not
useful to anyone else then you know what
it's I think of running for me like I
don't enjoy running I know it's probably
good for me but there are other ways for
me to exercise so it's not gonna make me
happy
and it's probably not that useful to
others relative to other exercises and
and so I think of running where yet it
is it's smart the smart thing to do is
to exercise but there are other ways to
accomplish that task the final thing is
it useful to others I think that's
important but if you're just giving
giving giving giving eventually you're
going to be empty and so you need to get
as well and I think that's what those
first two circles would recommend is you
have something that makes you happy
something that is good for you long-term
some smart and something that is useful
for the for the greater good and if you
can find the intersection not just the
two of those but of all three of those
and if your collection of stuff fits
into all three of those I think of a you
know they're like toy museums
yeah and that that's one way it can be
useful for a lot of people it doesn't to
be a museum where thousands people show
up you can have a collection that's
useful to all the people
and your your group or your your tribe
so to speak and so if you can find the
intersection of those three things then
I think you're going to be able to
justify a lot easier the things you
bring into your life because they
actually are going to make you happy and
those tears will turn into tears of joy
then yeah and all those things that you
have right now I know a lot of that you
don't have to have ownership of - and
joy meaning when you go to these
comic-con event comic-con conventions
you will have access to I'm sure stacks
and stacks of comic books that you can
look at I'm sure a lot of these are also
online so that's just something else to
think about - a lot of the stuff that we
bring into our lives that we think we
need to have ownership of to enjoy
really sometimes we just need to have a
little bit of access to it our next
question is from Tristan and Phoenix I
was curious
that's whether you guys shop at Costco
or Sam's Club or anything like that
because on the one hand I see you're not
wanting to buy a whole bunch of stuff
that you don't need in bulk but then
there are those items that you can buy
the best places that you do need like
toilet paper and paper towels and stuff
like that
so I was just curious if you guys did
that because I could also see it on the
other side being a time and money saver
but then also it would increase the
clutter in your happy amount of stuff
you have to take care of you know I
think we can answer that question
without a problem but but by me
answering that question or by Ryan
answering that question it's not really
going to necessarily help you
specifically yes I will buy a few things
in bulk because I don't think of money
as my only resource the space that I
have is a resource my time that I'm
going to use to go to the store
repeatedly like imagine if every time
you need to use toilet paper you went to
the store would be insane it would just
take up so much of your time right and
so I buy toilet paper in bulk I tend to
buy
I don't use many paper towels but I buy
paper towels in bulk and I usually have
to buy them maybe once a year and I'll
make sure I ask some important questions
first though you have to identify what
bulk is right I'm not going to buy a
literal ton of toilet paper I don't have
the space for that but I do have the
space for a larger bulk container of
toilet paper and and so I I'm going to
ask that question it do I have the space
for it and then if I do have the space
for it the next question asks after that
is is this getting in my way and so you
mentioned clutter there a moment ago
Tristan yes it if it gets in the way
than it is clutter for me I have to get
it out of the way I for me it's out of
sight out of mind but I want to be able
to store it to stow it in a place that
is never going going to get in my way so
that's going to help you identify how
much bulk is appropriate for your life
and then the other question it's
important to me is does it bother me now
as a person who has a very mild form of
OCD everything bothers me so does it
bother me enough that it is that is in
my way that it's sort of activating the
back of my mind and and does it seem
problematic and so I will buy bulk
things when I do need them and we often
make a distinction here these aren't
just in case items I won't buy bulk just
in case I'm going to have some toilet
paper just in case no toilet paper is
just for when I know I'm going to need
toilet paper and most of you know that
you're going to need a toilet paper that
is a just for win item now buying the
the next just in case item is a little
bit different something I might use in a
hypothetical future but I'm not sure
when and if I'm on to myself I'm
probably never going to use it that is
different there are maybe half a dozen
things that that I'm that I have in bulk
toilet paper paper towels hot sauce I
love some hot sauce yeah and between
Becca and and myself like we must go
through a gallon a month of hot sauce
so yeah no I yeah I don't I don't buy
much many things in bulk but I mean
that's because my Ryan I don't need to
buy a lot of things in bulk
I mean her question was do we shop at
Sam's Club or Costco Mariah and I went
to Costco once because she got a free
membership through work she was like oh
we can go and get some bulk vegetables
and some other stuff for smoothies and
you know at the end of the day the the
produce we got it wasn't like the best
produce I'm not putting their produce
down I'm just saying it but we would
prefer to get it somewhere else it
didn't save us that much money when it
came to buying produce oh and by the way
like there was only two of us so some of
it went bad yeah I think that's a good
point bulk perishables is generally a
bad idea unless you know I mean what we
were making a bunch of smoothies and
stuff yeah thought we were going to use
it all but I don't totally agree had to
learn the lesson the hard way there so
yeah we did it once it didn't really
work out for us but you know at the end
of the day if you got a family of seven
um it might it might make sense to go to
Costco and buy all that stuff in bulk it
just depends on what your circumstances
are certainly I don't look for those
places I don't go out of my way to go to
those places yeah and you know it's
interesting I don't think I I can't tell
you last time I was in a Sam's Club or
Costco I know that Costco I used to
listen to Clark Howard's radio show a
lot he's a consumer advocate and he he
would talk about and some of the some of
the best deals you could buy on random
things even automobiles they did at a
time ago I mean you know big screen TVs
before the the price was was relatively
inexpensive and and while we're not
advocating buying any of those things it
is part of the the conscious consumption
process is is the price and making sure
you aren't overspending I'm all for
spending more money for higher quality
I'm not in favor of spending more money
for no reason at all and and so
sometimes these bulk places like a
Costco will help you save some money
when I buy in bulk it tends to be things
I can get in bulk at a place like the
good food store Target or my local
market and so yeah I would just keep
that in mind what is is going to be is
it a just for win item
just in case and am I actually going to
be able to use this for the things that
are perishables and maybe not and you
could have a lot of waste involved so so
be responsible ask the right questions
and then feel good about buying and bulk
it once you've asked those those right
questions because you're saving time
which is a non-renewable resource now
we'd love to hear what you all have to
say so if you have a comment about
consumerism or shopping or buying in
bulk or comic-con or anything else then
feel free to leave us a comment now now
keep in mind we air for more comments on
this podcast then we do questions we get
a lot of voicemail questions that I'm
sorry but we just can't possibly answer
all of them we have a huge Bank of back
questions that we will go and answer
eventually so feel free to to comment
you're much more likely to have your
comment out there plus we want other
people's perspective Lee Ryan and I are
the experts because we decided to call
ourselves the minimalists and we've been
living this lifestyle a very intentional
lifestyle for the last six or so years
but we certainly don't have all the
answers but when we combined you know
half a million people who are listening
to this thing with us we might get most
of the answers so we'd love to get your
voicemail comments that's the best way
to comment just give us a call leave us
a voicemail at 4 o 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 and
what we'll do is we'll air our favorite
comments on and our favorite minimalism
tips on an upcoming episode and if your
voicemail is selected if we do select
your your comment we will send you an
autographed copy of one of our books
either essential which is is a
collection or minimalism live a
meaningful life or my favorite
everything that remains okay let's move
on to our our itunes comment of the week
alright this one comes from a king of
cinema out of santa barbara california
king of cinema writes we are in one of
the most beautiful places in the US but
it seems like all I can think about is
money we are spending too much to keep
up with the Joe
we are paying so much for a place that
we are really just using to store all
our stuff after discovering your podcast
I've spent the past three weeks using a
lot of the ideals you created and the
result has been amazing keep on rockin
yeah thank you
yeah thanks can you cinema you keep on
rocking appreciate that comment it will
send you a copy of everything that
remains and thank you to everyone else
who has left us an iTunes review we've
seen a lot of really awesome positive
honest reviews some really clever ones
too so feel free to get creative we'll
select our our favorites for future
episodes future episode I tune comments
of the week okay let's move on to our
hashtag ask the minimalists lightning
round we are on Twitter and Instagram
and now periscope looking at this this
camera right now and it's looking at
Ryan we are on Twitter and Instagram and
periscope at the mentalists and
facebook.com slash the minimalist you
can ask us your questions there alright
our first question is from Anne and
writes you talked about how following
your passion is crappy advice but
cultivating your passion is great advice
can you talk more about the difference
and why one is better we hear this
advice all the time right I was over at
the University recently and I saw a
poster on the wall that yeah so where we
are our office here at asymmetrical
press which is just a room is this
startup incubator here it's situated
across the river from the University of
Montana but we're sort of by proxy part
of the university here and I was over
there we were doing a radio interview
and they had a poster in the hallway
that said follow your passion and it's
like one of those successor II kind of
post it sounds great it sounds like
great advice and and you hear it sort of
propagated on blogs and self-help books
and and from professors and and well
doers people who want to give you good
advice because it sounds like great
advice but when you think about it it's
crappy advice
follow your passion presupposes that you
were
and to do one thing that you are meant
to be a yoga instructor or a teacher or
an astronaut or a writer or a plumber or
an electrician but the truth is there
are dozens of things that any of us can
be passionate about and so the better
advice is to cultivate a passion now
what does that mean with what's
different what's the difference between
follow your passion and cultivate your
passion and first off we have a whole
chapter in our book essential I'm going
to send you a copy of that book a whole
chapter in there about about passion and
success and how we can identify that but
if I were to look at cultivating a
passion it really means finding
something that aligns with your values
something aligns with your interests and
being willing to put in the hard work
don't confuse excitement with passion
just because you get excited about an
idea it doesn't mean you're necessarily
passionate about it
be willing to Drudge through the
drudgery to get to the other side to
actually experience a payoff but when it
gets boring or mundane or tedious or
monotonous then you know that you have
to continue to work through that because
if you don't work through it you'll
never get the real payoff the real
passion comes after the hard work after
the drudgery after being willing to to
put in the time and attention required
to create something meaningful and the
cool thing about that is there are
dozens of things that you could be
passionate about so some of you may say
I have no idea what I'm passionate about
that's okay because there isn't a thing
for you to be passionate about
in fact over your lifetime you can be
passionate about many things the key is
to find one thing put in the work
cultivate that into a real passion all
right our next question is right along
the same topic about passion it's from
Danny and Danny writes I am struggling
more with how to channel my creativity
into one project full-bore and not
bounce from one thing to another in an
endless list of options how do you guys
personally choose which creative outlet
to concentrate on and please don't just
have an answer of do what brings you the
most joy you know
listen to our podcast a lot doesn't it
it's funny because I would say someone
gives you that advice do what makes you
happy
wow that's more bad advice if someone
says follow your passions I don't want a
passion about just do what makes you do
it gives you the most joy yeah yeah uh
no you know who does what makes them
happy what gives the most joy Ella does
kids yes oh two-and-a-half-year-old
right or no for no no it's a reptilian
it's the reptilian brain yeah it's that
that mammalian what does a prefrontal
cortex that makes us just pursue more
and more and more impulse and act on
impulse
doing what makes you happy is not a
recipe for long-term happiness
surprisingly right yeah because doing
what feels good in the moment generally
doesn't feel good long-term you know if
I were to just do what made me it
brought me joy well well we want to be
doing this podcast right now I guess
that's true so I mean we have we have we
have you know mammalian impulses for
sure and it's okay to act on those but
but the truth is that that I want to I
want my short term actions to align with
my long term values and when I can align
those two it may be drudgery in the
moment but often that outcome is going
to be far greater than simply acting on
impulse this morning Ella would not let
me take her pee-soaked shirt off and and
she was fighting it and and you know she
was acting and she was yelling and you
peek that's what we know and like going
a little crazy but that's what that's
when we act strictly on impulse we act
just like that it's okay to be childlike
it's not okay to be childish and I like
to make that make that distinction so
when I'm trying to find something to
cultivate into a passion I have two
recommendations here one is pick a thing
and two is
for me it needs to to align with growth
and giving am i does this task does this
create creative endeavor allow me to
grow as an individual and does it allow
me to contribute to the greater good
contribute to the world around me in a
meaningful way if it fulfills both
criteria then I know it's something
that's worthwhile mmm yeah I think about
Tony Robbins uh the ultimate success
formula uh-huh so you know when I'm
trying to choose something to focus on
or if I'm from faced with a bunch of
options I'm looking at each option and
I'm kind of applying this formula of you
know the first step is figure out what
your outcome is so if I want to pursue
guitar you know and that's something I
want to make time for then I've got to
think about what that outcome is like am
I going out come to being a band into
playing a live show or is it just so I
can learn some chords and maybe you know
play a few songs around the campfire
like really what is my outcome and is
that how is that outcome going to affect
my life so for me you know let's take
guitar for example it's not something I
put a whole lot of time into right now
because I would love to learn how to
play guitar but at the end of the day
it's not going to give me a better
outcome than if I am here recording this
podcast certainly you know it's
interesting you say I learned to play
guitar in my mid-to-late 20th of 27 when
I bought my first guitar and I say learn
to play guitar I wouldn't ever play in
front of a crowd of more than myself and
I was writing a novel at the time it's
called as a decade fades and the main
character was a singer sir is a singer
songwriter and was is is he still out
there man I don't know my guess you'll
have to get to the ending now so in as a
decade fades Jodie Grafton is a main
character and he's a singer-songwriter
and I want to be able to identify with
with that sort of creative process and
so my outcome wasn't being able to plan
from in front of a group of people was
be able to understand the intricacies of
that how someone else might approach
this instrument and and and get better
at it what's the process of improving
and so I think that formula is important
what
what is my outcome is the most powerful
question that we rarely ever ask
ourselves we step back in that that can
go for picking a creative endeavor it
can go when we're about to get into an
argument with our significant other
what is your outcome is your real
outcome to to show that you're right
because even if you're right and
everyone's mad then you're still wrong
right and so we need to be really
careful about what do I actually want to
get out of this this behavior and if
you're able to answer that question man
that that can take what you're doing in
a totally different direction all right
let's move on to our next question this
is from Karina Karina writes I really
want to declutter my life but feel
guilty about doing so because most of my
possessions were paid for by my parents
and I wouldn't want to seem ungrateful
by getting rid of all the stuff they
provided me with all my life any advice
for people who may not yet have their
own income and whose family might not be
into minimalism yeah um you know that
this there's no harm we were just
talking to our producer Shaun about this
and he was like you know my mom will do
this get me something and if I don't use
it or if I don't need it I will and I
need to get rid of it it's no longer
serving a purpose or bringing me joy
I'll go back to her and say hey do you
want this back and I think there's no
there's no harm and asking that question
to your parent that's probably where I
would start so if I was in your position
I'd probably go to your parents and I'd
have a conversation that starts the
conversation off with something like wow
mom and dad you are great you've given
me all this stuff you giving me a great
life I really really appreciate it and I
want to make sure that the stuff that
you've provided me is getting the most
use is it people are getting the most
use out of it so is there anything that
I have that you want back that you feel
like you could get use out of or is
there anything that I have that you
absolutely don't want me to get rid of
and if they give you permission to go
ahead and let go of some of the things
that they've purchased for you and that
is no longer serving a purpose or
bringing you joy then yeah great get rid
of it uh go donate it so someone else
can get use out of it or maybe you need
to buy I don't know a refrigerator or
maybe you really do want to play a
guitar and you don't have a guitar you
need to buy a guitar you go to your
parents and say I'm going to sell some
of this stuff so I can buy
there are plenty of ways to approach
that so having it having a conversation
being loving being honest with your
parents this is really what's going to
help you get through this this decision
that you're trying to to make right now
and ask yourself whether or not your
parents want you to hold on to something
that isn't bringing you joy something
isn't serving a purpose in your life do
you do you really think that they're
going to think of you is ungrateful
because you're wanting to let go of
something that's no longer serving a
purpose no in fact if I was your dad I
might look at at you and say wow you're
holding on to something you're not
getting any joy from it all
and you feel obligated wow that's not
being grateful for the thing that you
had because here's a nice thing you can
be grateful about the thing and you can
also let it go later when it's no longer
serving a purpose we all we all live
through seasons and so does our stuff
right and so this thing in my life this
widget in my life had its season and it
went from spring to summer to fall and
now it's winter and it's time for it to
to find a new home find someone else who
can get value from that thing and maybe
you can make some money from it along
the way or maybe you can just get some
more value because you've gotten the
excess out of the way and that allows
you to start to focus on what's
important to you which clearly aren't
these things so you were grateful that
your parents got these things for you
right and that's great that you can show
your gratitude through your actions but
holding on to them out of an obligation
is not a action that is congruent with
gratitude keep that in mind as you're
holding on to things that no longer
serve a purpose
all right our last question is from
Robin Robin writes how or where do I
even start following your suggestions /
advice your podcast your first book well
Robin just go ahead and purchase
everything in fact purchase two copies
of everything and give them as your
friends of Hamlet no I'm kidding you can
go to the minimalists dot-com slash
start that's where I would tell you to
start there's a lot of free content a
lot of a lot of things you can dive into
if you're an audio learner if you if you
learn better audio than yeah start with
the podcast
if you learn better by reading than
start with our essays but yeah first
place is the minimalists comm / start
yeah totally agree I mean you can check
out our TEDx talk which is on that start
page as well and in terms of books if
you really want to take a deep dive
Robin I'm gonna send you a copy of
everything that remains that that's the
book that I recommend starting with and
then if you want to dive deeper from
there because that's really the y2 book
the the book that goes through my
journey and Ryan's journey from
suit-and-tie corporate guys living the
conventional American dream that wasn't
making us happy to becoming the
minimalist or first-month just
minimalists and then the minimalists and
and that whole journey but over
five-year span and from there you can go
to minimalism live a meaningful life
that covers the five values of living
more intentionally and our essay
collection which is called essential as
the third book I would recommend that's
the sort of rounds out the trilogy
that's more of the Hal to book it has
twelve different chapters of twelve
different themes from minimalism and
stuff to gift-giving and passion and
finances and and everything in between
mindful living and all of these areas of
living a more intentional more
deliberate life and we like to sort of
focus on those one essay at a time where
150 essays and in that collection so
Robin you can start there anyone else
who's interested in any of those books
you can just go to your local library
and you can usually find a copy there if
you can't they can generally order them
for you and if you decide to make a
purchase of one of our books that that's
fine but we encourage you to minimize it
afterward you can find them used online
as well or you can once you've read it
you realize the values in the words the
value isn't in the artifact itself so
pass it on to someone else who who
certainly can get more value from it
than if it just sits on your shelf and
forever all right Ryan we should move on
to our added value portion of the show
this is where we each recommend we
didn't talk about this beforehand we're
not going to recommend the same thing
we reach recommend some that has added
value to our lives before because we're
talking about consumerism today there's
a book called suffocation by James
Wollman and he's a British journalist
who wrote a journalistic approach toward
this this consumer culture that we've
been steeped in and so in suffocation he
he takes very much the the journalists
approach with with facts and figures and
stories and quotes in fact the book
opens with opening chapter with Ryan and
his his story of going through this this
interesting packing party so
stuffication is probably the best title
of any book that I wish I would have had
because it perfectly encapsulates this
consumerism idea we are suffocating with
stuff we are stuff ik ated my
recommendation I just had my family over
it was crazy man we had a seven people
in my two-bedroom apartment and it was
well it's funny cuz like he's not a big
two-bedroom no it's not it's a have two
couches and I had an air mattress so
like to family members shared the guest
bedroom and then to slip you know one on
each couch and then one on the air
mattress
but I was like totally looking at it
like oh my god like actually I'm doing
this I'm actually doing this in a small
place and I've got all these people
staying with me and it was not
uncomfortable it was it was fine but
while they were over my mom she was like
Ryan I really want you to sit down and
watch this documentary called racing
extinction and I kind of looked it up
and it was about um it's an
environmental movie and I gotta be
honest man like I am so I'm tired of
being dragged around the block
emotionally with you know the
environmental stuff so but bills for my
mom I'm like okay I'll watch it it was
an awesome movie man and that's what I'm
going to recommend his racing extinction
and the reason why I was awesome the
reason why I really appreciated it was
because it still was you know this
emotional roller coaster but it just
gave a perspective on what we're doing
to this earth that I have not seen
before so if you're especially if
there's someone out there who like
really wants to get through to their you
know a friend or a family member just to
help them have a little bit different of
a perspective I think this movie would
do a good job of helping people change
his perspective on how they are
consuming and how they are affecting
this planet so racing extinction you can
get it at a couple different places I'm
not gonna sit here name all the sites
but just yeah well lit and you'll will
throw links to that and suffocation in
the shownotes to to this episode as well
so you'll be able to check that out at
the minimalists comm slash podcast let's
move on to our next segment which we
call right here right now this is where
we stop talking about us and start
talking about us know we we could talk
about some of the stuff we have going on
right now Ryan this episode even though
we are recording it like what is today
March 8 they won't post until March 29th
on on the blog so you all on periscope
you're getting this way away early
congratulations but when it does post we
do have will be a month away from going
on tour so we have a bunch of different
cities let me see if I can remember
these Ryan we are going to start in New
York City on May 1st yes and then man
it's going to be a whirlwind tour for
the next 31 days we are going to be here
in fact check me here Ryan well I'm
going to be in we're going to be in New
York City Sean's coming with us our
trusted producer Sean now why is that
important because we're going to do a
live version of this podcast on the road
and we're going to answer your questions
after the film screens as well so you're
paying to see that the film which is
really paying in the theatres we make
very actually were going to lose money
on the tour but that's okay because
we're getting out there and we get to
interact with a bunch of people but Sean
will be with us recording episodes for
for this podcast as well we're going to
be in New York City and then Ryan I'm
gonna just sound like Howard Dean here
go for it and we're going to New York
City and then we're going to Boston you
and then Washington DC and then Miami
and then Dallas and then Dayton and
Chicago and Seattle and San Francisco
and Los Angeles and Salt Lake City and
Mizzou
in Toronto and then we're gonna take
back the White House is that the only is
it the only way you can remember all
those cities was doing it like Howard
yeah no it's funny cuz this know what
they say like the more emotion you can
tie with something like the better you
can remember but yes that was perfect it
was right on the list
I think it's 13 cities but the
documentary is going to be in 400 cities
so please get your tickets now at
minimalism film calm just click on see
the film find the theater close to you
it'll be in about 400 cities and if
you're overseas don't worry we're still
working on overseas distribution we're
going to start with Canada and Australia
and then we're going to branch out from
there and eventually we'll have some
online distribution too so we want to
make sure that everyone has the
opportunity to see this film we're
really proud of it it's one of the best
things we've ever done
our director Matt the Avella is a genius
the folks aspire media who helped us out
with us producers on the film they are
phenomenal as well also a tuesdays with
the minimalists every Tuesday in March
and April we are we're live on periscope
and Twitter 7:00 p.m. Eastern entering
your questions on on that format so
we're actually going to take the
questions right there live as you ask
them which we've been enjoying a ton
we've had thousands of people who are
also enjoying that so so thank you for
tuning into that all the details to that
the minimalists comm slash Tuesday's I'm
teaching another how to write better
workshop coming up in June the last one
really filled up and I have limited
seats in this one but you can find all
the details at how to write better org
it's a one day workshop the last one I
did was a two-hour workshop that was
four hours and and that's I think was
three or four hours and we just
jam-packed it with stuff and we're going
to do that again I also teach a
four-week class but for those of you
can't do that you can find the one day
workshop and at least allocate some time
on how to write better which isn't just
how to write better blog posts or
stories or novels all that's included
but it's you could write better business
emails and that that's something that is
important I think the rising tide lifts
all boats and I'll help out some people
with that that's why I teach a writing
class online and finally want to talk
Ryan about about some meetups yeah don't
forget about minimalist or we've got
hundred cities across the world where
there are people meeting up and
discussing things that have to do with
minimalism and simplicity some groups
are doing tiny home tours some folks had
a minimalist architect come out and give
a presentation another one had a
professional organizer give a
presentation even though I still think
organization is just a cover-up for well
organized hoarding but anyway that's
beside the point
um no no I I do think that organization
is is important this but you know when
you have gotten rid of all your stuff I
know I like to stay as organized as I
can but anyway um yeah go to minimalist
org
to find your local meetup if you go to
minimalist Oregon you don't see your
city there that's alright we still have
a group that you can meet with at the
online city you can join that there are
gosh I think it's over 2,000 people
there now and at that page I can't even
keep up with that they're just like so
much that's also so much going on yet so
and there's so many resources people are
sharing so when you go to minimalist org
and you click on your city and it
they're free group groups we don't want
anything from you we don't require your
email address or anything like that it
takes you to all these different
Facebook groups and you can find your
group for your city and people share
best practices they share articles they
share resources you can find
accountability partners in there because
this is posting so close to the first a
month we might as well recommend 30-day
minimalism game to you know just right
around the corner a new month so play
the 30 day minimalism game find the
accountability partner team up and you
can find all the details for that at the
minimalists comm slash game yeah I was
going to say minimalist org there's a
ton of a ton of accountability people
that people can rely on
I mean people running through our groups
it's like yeah it's like every single
day I'll just see like you know these
posts of pictures of stuff people are
getting rid of so yeah if you're looking
for help if you're looking for support
go to minimalist dot org alright let's
let's listen to some voicemail comments
from our listeners hi guys my name is
Dominique and I'm from Calgary Alberta
thanks so much for your awesome podcast
I wanted to share some advice a friend
gave me about
of items you've recently required that
I've turned out not to have have brought
you a lot of value let's say for example
the item is a $50 shirt you bought a few
weeks ago but you haven't worn it
instead of looking at the money spent as
being on the item itself assign it to
the learning experience instead take the
item and go through some questions about
it like what seems so appealing about it
in the first place would I have been as
likely to go back and buy the day later
a week later do I already have something
similar at home does that thing already
bring me serviceable value would I be
willing to let go of something at home
when this new item replaced it even if
you want something intrinsic for your
money you can write down some notes
about the purchase let down experience
or send yourself an email and the value
has now come from the learning
experience and not from the object
itself that makes it much easier to let
go of hey guys my name is Aaron and
calling from Regina Saskatchewan Canada
and I just wanted to comment on your
sentimental podcast today in particular
I chose to sell some diamond earrings
that my parents gave me as a graduation
gift years ago and I don't wear them
because I just don't wear them and I
told my dad today that I I sold them he
passed the message on to my mother who
just called me to tell me that I
shouldn't have gotten rid of them
because it was a sentimental item and I
should have caught on to it and I told
her you know what mom this is part of my
minimalist challenge I needed to get rid
of the sentimental items I'm sorry but I
don't wear them and in the future I'm
going to maybe buy myself some bigger
ones and she said you know okay fine I
get it and you know you've got a good
price so you know that's okay hey Josh
and Ryan my name is Zach from Kingston
New York I was just calling regarding
something mentioned on the last podcast
about consumers and about a prisoner's
question about feeling guilty esta vania
purchase um one of the things that
really helped me and I'm in lien ilysm
journey is um is really thinking about
the impact that our purchases make and I
read once that every purchase is a vote
and if you view your consumption this
way you'll really
just things in a much more intentional
way so for instance I love a Big Mac but
I'm not going to purchase one because
I've informed myself about some
McDonald's practices
I am I watch this documentary called the
true cost which told me a lot about the
way clothing is made and who impact and
that has influenced the way I buy
clothing and these sorts of things so if
you educate yourself about those
processes it's almost a way of naturally
minimalizing because you're able to
purchase much more deliberately and
intentionally and know what the impact
of that purchase is all right so that is
it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalists give us a
call at four zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine and if you leave here
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without me
so tear your eyes or tea
me
you